more than 24 hours after election day we
still have
no clear winner in this presidential
race but joe biden is ahead in electoral
votes
leading president trump 253-213
we are paying special attention today to
nevada
arizona and georgia if he wins any two
of those
he will get to 270 that's the numbers
you know required for victory
biden is also way ahead in the popular
vote with more than listen to this
number
71 million people that's the most of any
presidential candidate in history we are
also tracking different reactions from
the candidates president trump is
suggesting there has been
fraud without any evidence and he's also
making legal challenges
by contrast former vice president joe
biden is calling for
patience all right o'keefe is following
all of this ed good morning to you
what do the numbers tell you this
morning well good morning tony right now
both arizona nevada are leaning towards
former vice president biden
and with those electoral votes he would
be right at the 270 needed to win he
wouldn't even need pennsylvania
the biden harris campaign is feeling so
confident it's already launched its
presidential transition website
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners
speaking in wilmington delaware former
vice president joe biden said he
believes
he's on the verge of history i'm very
proud of our campaign
only three presidential campaigns in the
past
have defeated an incumbent president
when it's finished
god willing will be the fourth biden's
chances of reaching 270 electoral votes
dramatically improved with projected
wins in wisconsin
and michigan on wednesday and he
delivered the same message he's been
running on
since he announced his candidacy so once
this election
is finalized and behind us it'll be time
for us to do
what we've always done as americans
to put the harsh rhetoric of the
campaign behind us
to lower the temperature to see each
other again
to listen to one another but president
trump
isn't backing down while he had no
public events on wednesday he took to
twitter to make multiple misleading and
false statements
he claimed victories in pennsylvania
georgia north carolina and michigan
this despite evidence to the contrary in
michigan and no official race calls yet
in the other states
the president's campaign is also
launching legal challenges in georgia
pennsylvania and michigan and is
demanding a recount
in wisconsin the trump campaign strategy
has been contradictory
on the one hand in states the
president's trailing in like arizona
they say the number of votes yet to be
counted will put the president ahead of
binding
but in states where the president is
ahead like pennsylvania
the campaign wants the votes to stop
being counted
mr trump dispatched his son and members
of his legal team to the keystone state
on wednesday
where more than 760 thousand cast
ballots have not yet been counted
it's not fair this isn't democracy
ultimately they want the u.s supreme
court to stop pennsylvania from counting
mail-in ballots received by friday
even if they were postmarked on election
day the high court previously refused to
do so
the dueling strategy by the trump
campaign is trickling down to the
president's supporters
in detroit protesters chanted outside a
ballot processing center
as the trump campaign sued to stop the
count of ballots in michigan
until they say election observers are
given better access
but election officials say that
challengers from both parties
were already inside the room
in georgia the trump campaign is suing
to ensure voters by mail receipt votes
by mail received after 7pm on election
day
are not counted the lawsuit alleges a
republican poll watcher witnessed a poll
worker bring a stack of ballots
from a back room and mix them with
ballots to be counted
as with the rest of the legal challenges
however there's been no evidence
provided by the trump campaign
so typically ballots are kept in other
rooms before they are then processed
depending on state law it's not unusual
i mean there's there's accusations here
that sound like something that they are
not
sounds like it's nefarious yeah it is
not it's all going to be sorted out
and there are poll watchers from both
parties observing
most of these uh uh secretary of state
offices have bipartisanship built into
them
that's right i should know that and this
is a process we don't typically see
because races aren't typically this
close
but counting does go on after election
day yeah
quite normally thank you